Obamacare the Affordable Care Act
whatever you want to call it do you even
know what it is it's a federally run
insurance exchange where Americans who
don't already have health insurance can
buy it better yet have to buy it or else
face fines it also expands Medicaid to
millions of low-income Americans meaning
it increases eligibility and federal
funding to the program states can decide
whether or not to expand Medicaid and
some have rejected it entirely
twenty-nine states plus the District of
Columbia have agreed to expansion and
sixteen point four million uninsured
have gotten health care coverage since
it passed in 2010 but 36 million are
still left without it